all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day I want to go record the
intro and this guy knew who I was so
what's going on homie but uh what we
will be doing here today is uh we will
be flipping things that people will be
using for raids so pretty much just all
armors are available right now the
prices are very volatile and uh yeah
there's just huge margins everywhere I
noticed this when I went to go sell off
a bunch of things because I'm not really
participating in raids I'm more so just
going to merge and kind of watch and see
what happens from afar but today
we have 100 Mil we have an hour and I'm
going to go ahead and just flip some
huge margins and uh hopefully we make a
lot of money I mean from what I'm
looking at right now I could almost
guarantee a Mill and a half I I'd say if
I don't get a Mill and a half this
episode was a failure but I feel like I
can almost guarantee it CU there are so
many big margins right now on just every
item in the game because people just
don't know what to do like right now my
ALT I'm buying super combat potions or
not super combats but super attack
potions for like 50 GP super tech 3 so
they don't buy in bulk but they're
definitely there this dude also knows
YouTube it Jesus Christ man it's crazy
being seen in game but yeah all right so
before this video begins and yeah I did
not make 123 mil in case you're
wondering in that hour but what I am
going to recommend for you guys God damn
it I'm just standing in the corner um
what I would recommend for you guys is
this video is insane I'll preface it by
saying this is the most I've ever made
an hour of merching I believe also on
top of that if you guys are going to do
this what I would recommend doing is
only merging items that are below their
current guide price like if you go to
the GE and the average price of
something is 15 mil and if the average
price is 15 mil and it's like actively
traded price is 13.5 merch that item but
if an item has an average of 15 mil and
it's actively traded price is 17 don't
merch that because you know that the
item that is above the med price is only
there because of the hype of raids and
the only reason that the item below the
med price is that low is because it
isn't useful in raids or won't be as
useful at that exact time so over time
as raids become less popular those items
will slowly go back to where they were
and you won't lose money however the
other way around definitely definitely
more more risky just letting you guys
know all right so before we get into it
if you guys heard I will be using the
site GE tracker they are a sponsor of
mine they're just very helpful for using
the grand exchange and stuff like that
so if you merch a lot check them out in
the description but without further Ado
let's get on into this and we will get a
timer going all right so there we go the
timer is going go can't even tell going
to go ahead and find some items right
now so one that I have on my list is
amula torture I'll try to merge about
two of these at a time the price is
really low right now so makes for bigger
margin since I mean it's not really
around the Practical GE price so as you
guys can see there that is an insane
margin and I almost feel bad for even
selling that we're going to go ahead and
try to buy three um other than that I'm
going to try to go for some lower price
stuff while we have these things
flipping so uh I wanted to do necklace
of anguish but obviously that's not
lower price and uh kind of be counter
counterintuitive from what I'm trying to
do so uh there we go let's go ahead and
check out what cills is currently
merching for all right so as you guys
can see there that's a good uh 74k on
kill's tops you guys might not think
that that's the greatest but for how
quick these things buy and sell I'll
definitely take that all right and
luckily enough one of the Tores already
has bought which is great because I
didn't want to get screwed over with
that being My First Merch of the video
and it not being being able to buy for
that price so I was definitely nervous
but there we go got lucky with that and
as you can see the merch is already
flowing in I haven't started the timer
but I can guarantee you oh no I did I
did I just don't have it up there we go
okay I was I was nervous all right going
to go and uh we'll check out Eternal
Eternal boots I would imagine that's
pretty low cost and uh there could be a
decent margin on them so I'm going to
check them out yeah so I mean you know
99k margin it's good for what would
normally be there so I mean you know
it's all right but we definitely could
get better than that but for now we'll
settle with it I imagine one item that
has a really good margin right now there
we go okay two torchers bought that is
great that's what I like to see there we
go so all of the kill's tops have bought
which is huge and there we go so that'll
be a good oh man all of the Torches have
bought I might lower this price just a
little bit I don't think I need to lower
them too much but yeah as you guys can
see right now before raids the GE is
insane with just people trying to buy
and sell things it is nuts as you guys
can see I'm just getting a ton of items
right now so all these death runes we're
gonna be able to go ahead and make 13 GP
off of which will give us a good 130k on
top of that what we're looking for right
now with these Amulet of tortures so I
did have to buy the margin which made me
lose about 300K but I'm selling on two
more so I should be able to make about
600k once these all sell off hopefully
they sell quick and didn't just drop on
me but I have faith that they will
indeed sell there we go that is huge one
of my amula of torches sold on which
means I have the highest sell offer
which is great also on top of that the
dragon fire Shield according to GE
tracker right now has about a 600k
margin which I wouldn't doubt because
it's 3 mil over its main price so no one
knows what the hell the seller buy it
for so that's huge I'm just taking a
guess on that I don't want to actually
buy and sell that margin because that's
really big and I don't want to lose 500k
to maybe get a margin that I won't even
be guaranteed to have all right Amulet
of tortures are insane right now as you
guys can see they're still flipping just
insanely quick I'm going to hit my limit
on those which is sad but what I'm going
to do now is ring of sufferings these
things are so overpriced for what they
actually should be my bad but yeah they
are 3 mil more than torches right now
which makes no sense as they both come
from the same Jewel so it's just
ridiculous but I'm going to go ahead and
buy the margin because I'm not entirely
sure as to what I never mind I'm not
buying that margin please don't buy that
all right so now what I'm going to do is
sufferings apparently you can buy for
17.3 so I'm going to go well
17365 we'll go ahead and try that if
they don't buy up it but what we know
from that is I can make 300K on each of
these if they do indeed buy which is
utterly insane I'm going to try to put
these towards like dragon bones or herbs
or something something I know will be
bought and sold even ridiculous items
that would never be even used in raids
like band's God swords right now have
80k margins which are actually pretty
huge for that considering that's the
easiest like most easily accessible
merching item that anyone would think of
but we got things buying and selling
right now so I'm going to give it time
and uh we'll see what we get all right
so there we go another torture is sold
off um pretty much everything is just
kind of working it's magic I guess uh I
did end up putting in an offer for
Dragon Fire Shield as well as ring of
sufferings I upped a little bit ban
godwords are actually going which is
pretty nice um we've been able to merch
two of them already so uh about to merch
another two more off of this another
kill's uh leather top sold so I'm going
to go ahead and try and buy some more
tortures here soon I'm going to hit my
GE limit on them which is kind of going
to suck because these things are are
insane right now but uh you know it
happens all right so as much as this is
going to pain me I'm going to go ahead
and find the margins on the Ring of
suffering and the dragon fire Shield I
did it with the torture ornament or not
the torture ornaments but the torture
amulet so I feel as if it is only right
that I do it with these God the amount
of money I'm about to lose on these it's
insane though I'd rather just make up my
own margins but God damn it oh this
better buy
okay that didn't buy I do not care I'm
not buying it for more than that because
it is not worth more than that dragon
fire Shield however I will try and find
the margin so that didn't even buy all
right here's what I'm going to
do these things are just I guess flying
off the shelves so I'm going to go ahead
put an offer for that I feel like that's
respectable that's a good 500k profit
from what we've been able to find also
in ring sufferings I'm just going to go
over to GE tracker and put it in for
like 200k over whatever the hell price
it says it is right now so ring of
sufferings apparently from what GE
tracker is saying I should buy it for
around
17400 I'm going to go
17555 I know it's insane to just go that
far over med but as you guys saw I just
put my offer in for like 18.6 and it
didn't even buy so I do not know what
else I'm supposed to do yeah for some
reason this thing the timer wasn't
going yeah I didn't stop that on purpose
but for some reason last I guess while
recording this clip it probably wasn't
going so death runes are done I don't
even know if I made money off of them
but I wanted to get my money out of them
since they were just sitting there and I
knew that they weren't going to be able
to sell for that so went ahead and
bought one and sold them on for a little
less but as you guys can see big merch
right here if this ring of suffering
goes through all right so there we go
went ahead and found out another item
that has some pretty good uh margins on
it so that's about 160k on hostas and I
think you can sell or buy and sell one
like once every 3 minutes so I'll
definitely hit my margin or my uh 4 hour
limit hopefully if uh if I have enough
cash available at some point but uh yeah
we're kind of waiting for everything to
sell off so it's kind of you know a
little bit annoying but we'll get there
ended up selling off the haa that I just
bought however I did then find out that
there's 220k margins on zami and Spears
so just the most insane margin I've ever
seen I don't know I mean these these
dragon fire Shields aren't buying so I
guess I'm just going to go ahead and
find the margin cuz I'm just a [__] and
I really want to merch these since I
know that they are bought and sold a ton
an hour and I'm definitely going to
regret it whenever I end up buying this
shield for like 20 but okay that's not
bad I don't regret that I do not regret
that one bit okay that's not anywhere
near the margin I expected and I'm
thoroughly disappointed are you [__]
kidding me look at that that is a 1.1
mil merch right there and that took like
15 minutes not even I wouldn't even say
that much but that is legitimately
insane I'm going to go ahead and merch
one dragon fire Shield I think I just
want to merch one to get my money back
on these but other than that I kind of
want to do um Abyssal Legends or at
least one I guess because uh they have
pretty good margins right now and we're
going to get our money back off of these
am rocki and Spears so we are rocking
right now feeling really good after that
ring of suffering so to be honest with
you Moment of Truth what can we do with
an Abyssal bludgeon so I don't know how
much cash I have do I have enough to buy
that I do not but this is a pretty low
number so I'm going to go ahead and see
what I end up buying this for so
38.8 I'm actually terrified I'm going to
try to sell this for 381 if it doesn't
sell then I'm just going to use that as
my margin because I don't
know God I missed it by 30k that is
annoying but another ring of suffering
did just buy which is great I'm really
happy about that so I'm going to go
ahead try to sell this try to keep my
cool because I just lost 700k testing
out Abyssal
bludgeons hopefully it pays off dragon
fire Shield just bought like this is an
insane time to merge not even like I I
don't I don't have any words to explain
what's going on right now this is
ridiculous that took me three minutes to
make that 1.1 mil oh my God bro like
just keep going just keep going dragon
fire Shield got done I don't know if I'm
going to mess with that anymore it has
150k margin which as you guys can see I
am finding on zamarian Spears more than
that so I feel like this money could go
to something better I'm thinking
anguishes but uh we'll check out some
stuff yeah I mean like I was saying I
can find this on an anguish that is
below its actual price so I'm definitely
going to get go and take that way over
that dragon fire Shield that is way over
its actual
price I don't know what to tell you guys
I literally have no clue what to tell
you about these rings of suffering man I
just I have no I have no explanations
for it none at all don't even know if
that was a minute or two later it was
ridiculously soon to when I just bought
that this is beyond ridiculous how much
money I'm going to make in this episode
and we still got another 22 minutes like
at this point I don't even know I could
have like three or four M if not more so
just found 150k margins on derox set I
just bought a ring of suffering as you
guys know M margin there if it sells
just sold off my last Bandos godsword
which is really nice 700k margin off the
bludgeon I just bought and another 150
off the necklace of Anguish and 150 off
this to actually get my margin that I
bought
back it's yeah you guys know how crazy
this has been I'm not going to say it
anymore until the end because I I just I
don't know
so here we are 11 minutes left and uh
the only thing really going for us right
now are these derox sets they are just
flipping just nonstop I'm about to hit
my limit on them though they're doing
really good for me as far as anything
else it's just kind of all come to a
standstill but I mean honestly though
it'll I mean the progress we already
have is utterly insane so I'm perfectly
fine with it if this stuff doesn't sell
by the end of the 10-minute Mark stuff
like the hostas and the spear I'll
probably probably insta cell maybe even
the necklace of Anguish but the Ring of
suffering and the bludgeon I would leave
in for like 10 15 minutes cuz the extra
Mill that it's going to get is I mean
may not actually be right towards the
video but by far worth it towards me
like ridiculous so I'm going to drop the
prices on these though to try to get
them to sell all of these things before
the 10-minute Mark hits all right so I
went to lower the price accidentally
sold it but I mean honestly it was 50k I
think it was 40K lower so that's no big
deal at all um going to lower the price
on everything else though and yeah so
apparently all always had all we had to
do was just lower the price a little bit
on the hastas I still think I can make a
little bit of money off these before the
time runs out I'm not going to try to
put too much of this money into anything
else if you guys did see though I am
buying another
another um ring of suffering if that
buys I mean it's just going to be huge
so it's fine with me I I mean the
minimum I'm going to make on those I
would imagine is 700k if I lower them to
like 18.2 I'd imagine it' still sell so
I'm perfectly fine with it all right
another ring of suffering sold I'm
actually not nervous but I do want to
sell these off so it doesn't look like I
like you know had them in Forever After
the time limit went up but I'm going to
go ahead insta buy one hopefully it is
my own that would be ideal it is not
17.4 what I just bought one for
17.5 I don't I don't know about this God
damn it all right right I'm going to do
what I can 18 or we're we're just going
to go something nice something nice 7
17995 or 955 I'm going to let those sit
we're going to let this time run out
because there's nothing else I can
really do I could do something but
there's nothing else I really want to do
I think if fit my limit on the derck so
I'm going to cut this short five minutes
early we're going to let all this sell
and I will be back so we're going to
make a lot of money I can tell you that
much I lied Legend sold we're going to
try to buy another one because I mean if
I got time I may as well try to make as
much money as I can and there we go that
is the timer so I'm going to take that
off now there we go it is gone so going
to take out this offer and uh yeah going
to try to let these rings of suffering
sell I'm probably going to have to lower
their price but it is what it is I'm not
going to lose money on them more than
likely but we should be good all right
so after a couple minutes I realized
these things probably aren't going to
sell it legitimately was a couple
minutes don't be like oh it came back
after an hour but
yeah so I lowered the price by a ton to
pretty much what I bought the last one
for and within a minute one's already
sold so that's looking pretty good and
uh yeah and there we go within the next
I think 10 to 15 minutes somewhere in
there I don't have the exact time but
there we go 52.2 mil I probably lost
like 250k off those in total but that's
perfectly fine and uh
boom would you look at that 106 do we
have anything extra
no we do not but we have
106 mil I made 6 mil in 1 hour of
merching before raids that's how crazy
the market is that is just like I mean
and honestly this video is going to go
up the day raids go up even then prices
still may be fluctuating just
drastically because of things being like
more necessary Than People initially
thought but one thing you do have to
realize is once raids come out there
will be items that people will find
useless and they'll D they'll dump like
if if a DFS at one point just becomes
useless for whatever reason say like it
just isn't I I don't I don't know I
don't I don't have the exact scenario
and neither does anyone or else they
expect it but there are items that will
just fall drastically or items that will
rise and you could get lucky but for the
most part all items have risen to their
Peak at this point so after this video
if you guys decide to do this just be
very cautious in uh what items you
invest in and kind of think about them
before you do them some stuff like
Bandos really can't just not be useful
but there are like two-handed weapons
and stuff like that that could just be
just garbage so make sure to keep that
in mind that is 106 mil and I am more
than happy with it um I think I'm going
to pull an all nighter and raids come
out in a few hours so from there I'm
going to have a special episode for you
guys that will be a day long I won't be
on all day but I will be merching for a
day probably in total and seeing how
much I can make off of raid and like
actual armor if I'm able to buy any I
have about 250 to 300 mil so I'd imagine
I could get my hands on some sort of
items but uh that'll be it for this
video hopefully you guys enjoyed I know
I had a lot of fun merching this this is
how margins used to be just insane but
now with videos like mine and a lot of
other people that do merching stuff
margins have gone down the ton but it is
still really viable and uh yeah so if
you guys enjoyed the video make sure to
hit the like button if you guys want to
see future videos of mine as soon as
they come out make sure to hit the sub
much appreciated if you do that also go
over and hit up the Twitter that'll be
in the description down below and uh
yeah if you guys want to comment and
tell me anything go ahead and do that GE
tracker in the description if you guys
want to check them out and uh yeah other
than that hope you guys have a wonderful
day and peace and I still can't believe
we made six M like what
[Music]
d